-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actress.
You know her best from her work
in "Orange is the New Black."
She stars in "Dear Edward,"
which is available to stream
on Apple TV+.
Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
Taylor Schilling, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello, Taylor!
-Hi, Seth!
-I'm so happy to have you here.
-I'm so happy to be here
with you.
-I want to ask a lot about
you and your projects,
but I do like to always start by
talking about your dog Tank.
-Yes.
-And you shared some photos,
and it does seem like Tank
is just holding up so well,
aging so well.
Here's a photo of Tank up close.
And if you're wondering what
Tank looks like farther away,
there's Tank
slightly farther away.
How is Tank?
-He looks like Attila the Hun.
-Yeah. Tank is --
Don't take this the wrong way.
I found Tank to be a dog
with exactly one expression.
-She's working through it.
You know what I mean?
This is what I love about Tank.
Tank makes her way through.
-Uh-huh.
-Tank doesn't give up.
-Okay.
Do you think that is because
you named her Tank?
-Yeah.
-You put an
expectation upon her?
-She feel her own power.
-Yeah.
-And then,
when people are around her,
they can feel, in turn,
their own power.
-Oh, interesting.
She brings out the inner Tank
in other human beings?
-Yeah. That's how I feel.
-Does she interact well
with other dogs?
-Um, no.
-Okay.
-No, but I'm always telling her,
"It's not your fault.
It's mine."
And I tell other people that.
It's not her fault.
It's mine. I didn't do it.
-Oh, you didn't, like,
socialize her with other dogs?
-I didn't train her,
I don't think, properly.
But, you know, she tries.
-Okay.
-She tries.
She does this move
where she like, "Pbht!"
And, like, puts her kind of butt
in the other dog's face.
-Now, do you really -- Would you
describe that as trying?
[ Laughter ]
I would call that sabotage,
I feel like.
-The other day,
a dog-sitter texted me and said
Tank started doing
her butt-in-the-face thing
but was jumping off of a bench
into a pile of larger dogs.
So she said,
"We had to take Tank home."
-So Tank jumped and, in mid-air,
rotated herself so she --
That does not -- Tank does not
seem sort of the acrobatic type.
[ Laughter ]
You said one of her dog-sitters.
Does Tank kind of
go through them?
-She needs help, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, she's special.
-She's special?
-She's special.
-Are you having a good --
I mean, is the new year
off to a good start
with you and Tank?
-I mean,
we've had some health scares.
-Okay. You actually --
This is -- You have a photo.
And I do want to say, this is a
dog mom with great concern.
I mean this
with all genuineness.
Like, it seems like Tank --
There you are.
You seem - I should note,
you seem harried.
Tank looks exactly the same.
-This is a harrowing photograph.
-So, what happened --
It's very nice.
I do appreciate that
something was wrong with Tank
and you did not stop for
hair and makeup on the way.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. What happened to Tank?
Why was --
-Well, I mean, now I'm
thinking it might be from
all of the, like,
sort of dive-bombing
into groups of other dogs.
But she has -- You know,
she has a fragile back.
-Yes.
-So, she needed -- Oh, God.
-Wait. So, what happened?
Now, obviously, something
happened that you thought,
"I'm going to wrap my dog
in a towel
and take her to a vet."
What was the moment
that you were like,
"Oh, no,
something is wrong with Tank"?
-[ Panting ]
-Okay.
-Nonstop.
-And that's more energy
than we usually get from --
-Yes, she was just
panting nonstop,
and I thought, "She needs help."
And she did.
There was a problem
with her back.
But she didn't need surgery.
She just needed drugs.
-Okay.
Taylor?
If I find out
you're using Tank...
[ Laughter ]
If I find out
you're sending her out --
You're like,
"Throw your back out.
Throw your back out, Baby Tank.
Mom will take you to the vet.
50/50 split."
-Hell no, not today's take.
-Oh, yeah, that's true.
Last time you were here,
you showed us
a photo of your apartment.
It was very scary.
The lights were
going on and off.
-Yeah.
-Water was flooding.
-It seemed haunted.
-Yeah, it was.
-And, you know, it's nice --
I actually thought it was nice,
because you think of
hauntings usually happening
out in the woods
and, like, cabins.
It was nice that they
were moving into the cities.
Where are you now?
Do you feel better about
your current --
-I mean, it's an Airbnb still.
It's better.
-Okay.
-There's not --
Do you remember --
The shower came through the
ceiling in that other apartment.
-Yeah.
-That's not what
is happening here.
-Okay, that's good.
-It's nice.
Yeah, it's, like, settled.
We're settled, Tank and I.
-I think one of the nice things
that you've done for yourself --
because, again, you've been here
multiple times --
is each subsequent apartment
is still terrible,
but it's so much better
than your last one.
Like, you started at, like,
such a low floor.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, like, I shared with you
a long time ago
about my first apartment.
And now it's different.
Yeah, this one's different.
-Your first apartment in
New York City,
where was the bathroom?
-In the -- The bedroom and
the kitchen were the same thing.
-Okay.
-Yeah. The bitchen.
-The bitchen, right.
-Yeah.
-So, you were sleeping in
a room with a stove.
-Yeah.
-A working stove.
-Yeah. And a sink and, like --
-Yeah. Like,
all the kitchen stuff.
-Yeah.
And, like, a dish rack.
-You've come a long way.
-Yeah, yeah. Come on, like...
-You're doing alright
for yourself.
-Thanks.
-I want to talk to you about you
when we come back
after the break.
That's more than enough
about Tank.
I will be right back with
more from the wonderful
Taylor Schilling.